[Music]
a law banning treatments for transgender
youth including
cross-sex hormones and so-called puberty
blockers
is set to take effect next month in
arkansas and that state is the first to
enact such a measure
the justice department is now
challenging the ban and argues it
violates the equal protection clause of
the 14th amendment
republican governor asa hutchinson
meanwhile vetoed the bill back in april
but the gop-controlled house and senate
voted to override that veto
in a new episode of 60 minutes plus
correspondent seth done spoke with one
teenager at the center
of a widening legal battle over the bill
in arkansas
dylan brandt who legally changed his
first name last year
is now a plaintiff in a lawsuit along
with three other transgender
youth their families and two doctors
filed by the american civil liberties
union
the suit takes issue with arkansas house
bill 1570
first passed in march which bans for
minors what's known as
gender affirming medical care which
helps a transgender person
with their physical transition i'm on
testosterone and i've been on that for
10 months you'd
lose that if this law goes into effect
yes
what do you think about that it's it's
horrible
i was really insecure with myself and
not
happy before this i had a lot of
depression i
it was it was really hard
brandt is one of the roughly 2 percent
of u.s high schoolers who identify as
trans
with his little brother by his side as
he began transitioning at 13
he chronicled bits of it on tick tock
which his family gave us permission to
show
he went from long blonde hair to
appearing more masculine
with psychological counseling and under
supervision from a pediatrician
he started taking cross-sex hormones
by injecting testosterone my name is
dylan this
is my voice one day on t this is my
voice
two months on t marveling as his voice
dropped
it's my voice seven months on
testosterone
and nationwide more than 30 bills would
restrict the access of trans kids to
gender
affirming medical care those bills have
been introduced
this year alone and seth doan joins us
now
from athens greece not arkansas more on
that in a second but important story
here
seth good morning to you this aclu
lawsuit
could that affect the arkansas law going
into effect in july
yes tony good morning they are seeking
an injunction and they say it really
depends on what
the judge says but they hope to block
that law from going into an effect
and as you noted in the intro into our
story
they got a little boost late last week
from the department of justice which
issued that a statement of interest
supporting the aclu
lawsuit but it really depends on what
the judge says the aclu we spoke with
chase strangio who's the one of the
lawyers who will be arguing this case
and he says he believes it is
clearly unconstitutional for instance uh
someone who's not transgender a young
person going through puberty too early
could take a
puberty blocker but a transgender person
in the state of arkansas
after this law goes into effect in july
could not so he said it's clearly
discriminating against a certain group
of people
it's early but how might this law or how
has this law affected trans youth so far
well you saw dylan brandt he's the main
character the person who is
one of the one of the four transgender
youth who are behind this lawsuit along
with
two doctors and the families of the
transgender youth dylan took us through
his experience of
really a psychological journey for a
long time of just feeling like he was
not in his own skin doctors say this can
that his outsides didn't match his
insides and doctors say these feelings
can happen
as young as two to five years old and
then working with doctors this
this gender affirming care can begin
a little bit later all right seth down
on a very important story